[Musique]
nicolaï florilège s'enfonce dans la
forêt de guédelon will leur quête un
chêne qu'ils ne vont pas tarder à
dénicher
une belle formule 1
du fus en fait à une dizaine de mètres
on voit qu'il ya une franche courbure
qui peut nous intéresser pour la
charpente de la tour du pigeonnier
quand on a vraiment besoin d'armes enfin
de deux pièces de charpente assez
spécifique qu'on ne trouve pas ailleurs
on les prend ici
à guédelon le plus gros du bois vient
d'une forêt nivernaise à une quarantaine
de kilomètres mais le chantier cherche
toujours à s'alimenter au plus près en
pleine cohérence avec la réalité du
13ème siècle du local donc
à brno et à ce jeu là claire n'est pas
la dernière à
la carrière d'argile la peintre vient
prendre de quoi préparer ses couleurs
je viens de récupérer des hématite qui
sont des pierre qui
vont clés qui sont agglomérés dans
l'argile donc en fait là ce qui
m'intéresse c'est l'argile qui va donner
déjà une couleur et les hématite ensuite
je vais les broyer ça donnera donc une
autre couleur tous les matériaux qui
servent enfin les pigments sont trouvés
sur place autour du château
la carrière de pierre c'est elle qui a
imposé ici l'installation du château
j'ai détails un peu intermédiaire ge
durant théophile le masson vient
s'approvisionner la
même pas du circuit court c'est encore
plus court que ça c'était une thématique
plutôt d'actualité en ce moment je
transporte à l'époque au moyen-âge coûte
cher et avec la avec ce qu'il ya sur la
carrière et aurait de quoi construire à
peu près de château et de châteaux et
demi ce qui est quand même
impressionnant et on pourrait s'en
inspirer pour la vie ordinaire selon
vous selon moi c'est totalement faisable
en alliant peut-être aussi l'innovation
qu'on peut avoir aujourd'hui avec en
cherchant des matériaux qui sont jamais
très loin avec des matériaux comme la
terre crue mais comme ces pierres qu'on
a en fait sous l'os nos maisons
peut construire avec ça il ya beaucoup
de choses à en retenir
des leçons du passé pour l'avenir claire
peut aussi en donner de retour dans son
atelier elle prépare ses thématiques
la matière dans la nature on va la
transformer complètement est en fait
tout le processus en maîtresse comprend
au total pas moins de quinze couleurs
peuvent ainsi être créés de manière 100
% bio
j'avais beaucoup de visiteurs qui m'en
parlent qu'ils me posent des questions
qu'ils veulent reprendre des volets chez
eux par exemple et qui se demandent
comment ils peuvent faire pour utiliser
des pigments naturels donc je le vois là
je leur donne des petites astuces des
recettes après c'est pas notre propos
premier évidemment on est là surtout
pour expliquer tout le côté archéologie
expérimentale mais je pense que
parallèlement à cet aspect là il ya
aussi oui hein on peut montrer aux
personnes qui s'y intéressent qu il y a
des choses à faire apprendre en fait de
guénon pour les reproduire dans la vie
de tous les jours dans la vie moderne et
changer un peu le monde et changer un
peu le monde
circuits courts matériaux naturels
construction durable chaque jour un peu
plus les pratiques du chantier colle aux
enjeux de l'époque on souhaite que ça
puisse pousser des ingénieurs des
architectes toute personne à se dire que
c'est possible et que l'on peut imaginer
un monde un peu différent avec avec des
beaux matériaux des maisons habitables
des formes qui sont en continuité avec
l'environnement avec le patrimoine et
une envie de faire société un peu
autrement pour moi en tout cas ça ça
doit passer par là
réenchanter l'avenir bien sûr
guédelon un chantier médiéval une
philosophie aussi pour claire théophile
nicolas et les autres travailler et
vivre autrement